hi I'm Evan Carmichael I'm really
excited to be with you here today
because I've launched my first worksheet
for entrepreneurs on how to find your
passion if you look at any famous
entrepreneur and why they became
successful it's because it had a strong
passion for their business a lot of
entrepreneurs set up they want to make a
lot of money that's a great goal but if
you look at the people who just want to
make money they rarely do it's the ones
who have a strong passion for what
they're doing they have a need to help
people and they want to change the way
something is done those are the
entrepreneurs will end up going on to
build highly successful businesses and
make a lot of money in the process as
well so a lot of people understand that
I gotta find my passion but they don't
know how to do it how do you find your
passion and turn that into a winning
business idea I get asked a question so
many times and I thought the best way to
be able to answer that for you guys is
you create a worksheet so you can walk
through it yourself so this worksheet
what it does is take you step-by-step
through the process of how to identify
what you're passionate about and also
which passion has the best opportunity
to become a successful and winning
business idea for you so it's step by
step guide you're going to be filling
out different worksheets and filling out
a checklist that will help guide you
through that process to make it easy to
get that winning business idea and give
you an idea that can keep you motivated
and keep you excited and also helped a
lot of people and make a lot of money in
the process in addition and also be
sharing some quotes and advice from
famous entrepreneurs on how important
passion is to them and how they went
about finding the passion for their
business so hope you guys will check it
out up here struggling to think about
what business idea to come out with this
is going to be a really helpful tool for
you it's five bucks so it's not going to
break the bank to go through and as an
added bonus I'm also willing to help you
guys out i made this because i want to
see you successful my my passion is
helping entrepreneurs I love helping
entrepreneurs I love the impact that
they can have and when you give them
advice and you see that they take it and
they're off building their huge
businesses it's an amazing and extremely
rewarding experience so I want to see
you be successful so I want to be there
for you as well so if you buy the
worksheet you work you go through it if
you have questions afterwards if you
have questions along the way you're not
sure if you did something correctly if
you want me to review it afterwards just
email me send me an email give me your
questions your thoughts your filled out
worksheet I'm going to help you go
through that
because I really want to make sure you
start off on the right foot you're in
the business for the right reason and
you you can build a successful company
that you're not only going to make a lot
of money from but also be really proud
of of what you're doing so it's five
bucks you can order it by the links
below I hope you check it out and you
have any questions along the way feel
free to let me know thank you and we'll
see you on the other side
you